Film Courage: Looking back on it now, what
where the drawback and benefits to making
so many short films and do you think it was
worth it?
I know you wanted to make a feature film much
sooner.
Peter Dukes, Writer/Director: For me personally
it’s worked out just fine.
I’ve taken an unusual path.
I’ve taken a very patient path.
I wanted to prepare myself as much as possible
about my short films as I’d mentioned before
and I didn’t.
I didn’t want to get into the director’s
chair for feature and blow it.
It’s hard enough to get that first chance.
I didn’t want to get there and blow it and
never get another chance.
For me it worked out nicely but it took 15
odd years (whatever it was…10 years)?
Whereas other people go I’m going to go
for it from the beginning.
And again some of them make it early and since
they are younger than me…agencies love hot
up-and-coming talent.
So if you are a young mid-twenties and you
make something really cool you’re going
to get more attention then if I make something
cool.
It’s just kind of the way the business (at
least the industry out here) is kind of set
up.
I can’t say the way I did it is right or
wrong or what not.
I’ve always been a patient guy.
I’ve always taken my own road to things
so I think it’s been beneficial to me.
Obviously the drawbacks are I’m 40 and only
have (what will soon be) two features under
my belt and if I’d taken a slightly different
path maybe I’d have had 10 at this point?
But that’s a drawback I’m willing to live
with.
I think I did it the only way that it was
ever going to work for me.
It’s an interesting question because if
you ask 10 other filmmakers what they think
of my strategy they might laugh their heads
of from what I know (I don’t know?)
But it’s a weird business.
Everyone is on their own.
You are totally on your own.
You can read as many books on the subject
as you want but the reality is no one is going
to give you anything.
You’ve got to go out there and earn it through
talent and hard work, perseverance, all of
those kind of things.
Every filmmaker (myself included), every single
filmmaker I’ve ever met literally has their
own fascinating story as to how they got it
done, how they got noticed.
And some of them might be more successful
with others in terms of how far they’ve
risen or what level of movies they’re doing
now.
But all of them just literally found their
way through the labyrinthian maze that is
Hollywood and made it wherever they are these
days.
Film Courage: Can you recommend any resources
for young filmmakers starting out?
I know you said previously everyone has their
own path.
Are there resources that have been valuable
for you in terms of DIY, not only learning
about film theory or whatever?
Peter: Listen, I’m sure there are a million
books on the subject and I read many in college
that were perfectly fine, literally in terms
of people from a nuts-and-bolts, what do I
do?
How do I start directing at all or whatever?
I would recommend just getting on set, get
on as a PA (production assistant), get on
whenever you can, figure out how a [film]
set works.
You don’t have to become an expert at it.
You don’t have to spend five years on set.
But get on the set and figure out the world
you are going to be living in and leading
at some point as certainly as a director.
Know that world and that is the very seedling
to you starting to put together your own world.
I would recommend working at places that will
teach you what you need to know.
If you’re not on set go work at a camera
rental house.
Learn the gear.
If you want to get into writing and producing,
work at an agency, work at a management company,
work at a production company.
I would learn who is in your business, who
do you want to know?
There are a lot of assistants out there.
Figure out who works for who, network.
In terms of gear, become an expert at it.
You don’t have to become someone who is
paid $1,000 dollars a day to run the gear
but know it from a general standpoint.
Know what you need, what you don’t need.
If you’re writing, I would say one of the
best steps you could do is read great screenplays.
They are all online these days anyhow.
Read THE GODFATHER, read whatever you can
read.
Read new scripts, old scripts.
Read, read, read, and then read some more.
Figure out what made them great.
Then start writing yourself and write and
write and write.
It’s probably going to be pretty awful at
first, it will probably get better until you
start to find your own voice.
That’s what you do whether you are learning
the gear and pulling it together to start
tackling producing and directing your own
short film.
Whether you’re writing your own scripts,
don’t be intimidated by it, don’t be scared
by it.
Just do it and then you do it again and then
you do it again and again and keep honing
it until you learn what you need to and I
think both will learn along the way more so
than most books can tell you, learn through
experience.
Film Courage: You say that horror sparks conversation?
Peter: I think a great story sparks conversation.
I think horror can spark certain visceral
reactions.
I think a great film…my dream as a filmmaker
is to have one of my scripts or one of my
films cause an audience to leave the theater
and go talk about it and debate about it and
think about it.
I don’t necessarily want to make the type
of movie that they eat their popcorn, they
walk away and by the time they get to the
car they don’t remember what they saw (some
fun movie or whatever).
I think any great story (horror included)
is something that will make people talk and
I mentioned privilege before.
I do think it’s a privilege to be in a position
where I can build stories and characters and
tell stories that I think aim to make you
see the world and your place in it from maybe
a different perspective.
I think that’s a very powerful thing that
we do and have the ability to do and I aspire
to do an even better than I do so now.
But yes in short I think any great film should
spark discussion.
I think that’s the goal.
I think you should do something that inspires
you or traumatizes you or scares you.
Whatever reaction is the point of your story
I think that should always be the point (to
get a reaction) otherwise your film is just
putting people to sleep.
So that’s what I aim for.